so of all the people you've seen weigh
in on ukraine maybe none has put the
american position more succinctly or
expressed it more wisely than a man
called bryce mitchell we played a
portion of his comments on this show
yesterday bryce mitchell is a cattle
farmer from arkansas he's also a fairly
well-known ufc fighter last week he was
asked what do you think about ukraine
and here's part of what he said
i'm not going nowhere to fight none of
these wars for these politicians i'm
staying at home and when the war comes
to arkansas i will dig my boots in the
ground and i will die for everything i
love and i will not retreat if this
country is invaded and everybody's
saying well we gotta we gotta evacuate
we gotta leave we got i will not i will
dig my boots in the arkansas soil and i
will fight for the people that i love
for the land that i love and the way
life that i love but i'm not going
overseas to fight
i don't know what's going on
a lot of people you see on tv would
leave instantly if we were invaded
there's been polling on it shows it
pretty clearly you should pay attention
to people who wouldn't leave who'd fight
for their country and for their people
the ones they love
bryce mitchell's obviously in that
category he won his fight on saturday we
should tell you he promised to give half
the purse to a charity in arkansas to
help children with medical conditions we
are honored to have bryce mitchell join
us tonight bryce thanks so much for
coming on and for what you said
i haven't seen anybody express it better
than you did why did you say that
well thank you so much for having me
brother and i said that because that's
the first thing that i thought when he
asked me and i was trying to give him
the best answer that i could and that's
just my genuine thoughts on the subject
how do you get to be so honest when
everyone everyone else is afraid to say
what they think and you just kind of say
it
well i don't have to be
worried about being fired from my job
for saying what i want to say there's a
lot of people out there that do agree
with me but they can't say things that i
get to say even though they think them
they'll get fired from their job if they
come out and say it
dana white's pretty good with how he
lets us uh
talk and say what we want
that is that is absolutely right and a
fair thing to say now people who say
what you have said
are often denounced as unpatriotic or
traitors to their country does that
confuse you since the first thing you
said was i will fight and die
for arkansas
that'd be the greatest honor i could
ever have brother so i'm i'm far from
uh not being a patriot you know that'd
be the greatest thing i could do is die
defending this land so i'm not afraid to
do that i'm just not wanting to go waste
my life fighting for some of these
battles that i don't even believe in if
you know where i believe our
leaders a lot of these elites are guilty
of trees and what they've done is just
uh treasonous and you know and i'm sure
you know what i'm talking about a little
bit
it it's it's funny that they're accusing
you of treason um why do you think
almost everyone in the media and i mean
almost everybody and both political
parties and of course the white house
are all on the same page that you need
to get behind this war with russia why
is that so important to them do you have
any sense
well i don't exactly know what their
agenda is with the whole war on russia
but i do know that um all that money
that's going to the biden family through
hunter biden um he's not he doesn't have
the merit for that position he's got
over there they've used our tax dollars
to bribe him a job you know um if me or
you did what nancy pelosi did and got
millions in stocks we'd go to prison for
insider trading but she does it and and
she's filthy rich so these their
families are getting
very
greatly compensated while they're taxing
us to death inflation's higher than ever
they close down all of our pipelines and
wonder why the price of oil
has gone through the roof
these people are trying to destroy our
country because they are profiting off
the downfall of our country and if y'all
don't see what's going on you are
blinded every day
you know our inflation gets worse our
debt gets worse
our actual currency is controlled by a
small group called the federal reserve
that ain't federal and anal reserve so
it's uh it's insidious in nature it's
made to control we have a lot of
problems and it's going to take a lot of
things
to fix it
it's amazing it's amazing what you're
saying all of which is in my view true
so for our viewers who aren't familiar
with you because we were so struck by
that clip uh that we played last night
and part of it tonight we wanted we got
another clip this is you training at
your ranch in arkansas we're gonna play
[Music]
i'm training here all the time when
nobody's looking
i got a log out there that i curl and
then i lift it over my head and then i
run a circle and then i'll fill up the
wheelbarrow with dirt and push it around
the number one reason i won't go to a
big gym is because of the secrecy
your plants need to be dark as night
so that's where you live so i mean i i
think it's fair to say you're pretty
you're pretty rooted in the ground of
this country
well this country's made up of
you know small businesses and and people
like myself that are
anything from rich you know but um that
work hard every day and have goals and
that's
that's what this this whole thing is
attacking it's attacking a small
business the uh the mom paw shops you
know they're paying the consequences
all this uh coveted stuff it's killed
small businesses what they're doing
they're giving bailouts to the big
businesses and
in arkansas they shut down businesses
for three or four months however long it
was they wouldn't let us open up our
gyms and this and that and
uh we're tired of this politics crap
that's going on and so it's evil is
what's going on evil has took over this
nation and we ain't afraid of it and
we're ready to fight
i i think you're exactly right in your
assessment tell me about since that clip
of you saying that at the press
conference has spread so widely i've 20
people sent it to me
what are your friends and neighbors in
arkansas
say to you do they agree with you
i've had people coming out the woodwork
just supporting me and
then they've been telling me also you
know you need to load your guns up
because somebody's going to come out
there and try to take you out for what
you're saying and that that's how that's
how worried people are about the state
of their country my friends think that
my life is
uh it could be at risk because i'm
coming out here and speaking truth you
know i have people saying hey load your
guns up be ready so you know and that's
just i'm just telling you that's what
people are telling me right now you know
they they are worried about my health
because i'm coming out and speaking the
truth that's the type of suppression and
oppression that we're living in brother
people are worried about it
well you hate to think that's true but i
i know where they're coming from there's
a lot of malice out there i think you
speak for many people and i'm really
glad you're brave enough to say that
bryce mitchell thank you for joining us
thank you so much for having me brother
god bless you i love it
god bless you thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else